الاخضر يهزم الارجنتين الفيفا تسميها
المفاجاه الاكبر في تاريخ كاس العالم
وميسي يصفها بالضربه القاسيه جدا وكاميرا
تفاعلكم تاخذكم في جوله في بوليفارد بورد
اكبر مناطق موسم الرياض بعد افتتاح وجديد
يوميات ماسك تبعي بالانجازات والتنكيد
مستمر اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
مبروك مبروك مبروك لكل السعوديين والعرب
صقور الاخضر اليوم فرحوا ملايين السعوديين
والعرب بتحقيق فوز تاريخي ومستحق عن جداره
ضد الارجنتين في اولى مباريات المنتخب في
المونديال بهدفين لواحد هاشتاجات المباراه
ومن اول اليوم كانت ترند لكن كان غالب
عليها القلق والترقب وبعد مباراه ناريه
فعلا تالق فيها منتخبنا الوطني بشكل مو
عادي ولعب لعب مو طبيعي الهاشتاجات ولعت
اكثر واكثر والاحتفالات زادت اكثر واكثر
اولا التوقعات كانت كلها معي للكفت
الارجنتين باعتباره انه منتخب كبير وحامل
لللقب من قبل وبيلعب فيه ميسي ثانيا
بالفوز هذا المنتخب السعودي اوقف سلسله
اللا هزيمه للمنتخب الارجنتيني او همم
ستريك مثلا اللي هو فوز مثل ما بيسموه همم
بشكل مستمر من 36 مباراه تحديدا طيب
المباراه فعليه كانت كبيره واداء منتخبنا
فعلا كان كبير ويستحقوا عليه كل تقدير
وهذا مو بس احنا كلامنا الفيفا غردت بعد
المباراه ووصفت اللي صار بانه احد اكبر
المفاجاه في تاريخ كاس العالم ومسي قال في
تصريح بعد المباراه نصا قال الهزيمه امام
السعوديه كانت ضربه قاسيه جدا
دربنا اخضر
قلبنا اخضر
فلنه اخضر
كلنا الاخضر
درب الاخضر قلب
نا اخضر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بلا اخضر
بلا اخ
اف الله
عودتنا يا فخرنا لا خبر
[موسيقى]
كل ما حفا العالمين تفضل
وبعزه
بلادك
وتنهرب العصمك حزمك يا نادر
تكون في بدلكم يا عيالنا
يطوركم يرسم طريقه ديالنا وفراركم
دربي
الوفي
[موسيقى]
الليله الاخضر
[تصفيق]
متعوب
واستمتعوا
وارفعوا فينا الضمور
صحفين الضمور اتعبوا
برافو
حرب في قلبنا وروح قلبي وروح
العبوا لاحبابكم احبابكم
العبوا ولا اصحابكم اصحابكم
[موسيقى]
وبعدين انتهاء المباراه انتشرت كمان على
المنصات مقطع وصور لولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان وهو بيتابع المباراه وبيحتفل
بالفوز
احتفال وضحك وتنكيت وناسه كلها مسيطر على
الهاشتاقات والسعوديين والعرب مولعين
تويتر وهذا بعض ابرز المتداول
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دايما
دموع دموع دموع
[موسيقى]
بالزياره كسر عينه بالسياره
[تصفيق]
الارجنتين وليس لاعب واحد 11 ضد 11 ووعدنا
ان شاء الله يوم الثلاثاء
[موسيقى]
تالقوا في التعليقات صراحه ويا رب تكملها
معانا ان شاء الله والاداء يكمل كده ونفوز
في المباريات الجايه ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
افتتح رئيس هيئه الترفيه معالي المستشار
تركي ال الشيخ امس اكبر منطقه في موسم
الرياض 20 22 وهي بوليفارد بورد
الافتتاح لليوم ما زال هاشتاج افتتاح
بوليفارد ورد
هذا البوليفار بيقدم للزوار اكثر من 120
تجربه في 10 مناطق بتجمع حضارات من حول
العالم
[تصفيق]
تخيل تخيل
[موسيقى]
هلا قلب الرياض بالح
ب انا
ارحب يا هلا واهلا بالزايرنا
هلا قلب الرياض بالحب يجمعنا
يا
مرحبا ومن اول يوم تردد الاف السعوديين
والمقيمين على بوليفارد ورد الرياض
للاستمتاع بالتجارب المتنوعه ومشاهده
معالم العالم وهي جايت لهم في وسط الرياض
اكثر من 120 تجربه مثل ما قلنا 10 دول
ثقافات ومئات العروض الترفيهيه وغيرها
وغيرها وكل هذا مشاهدينا انجز في 82 يوم
بس بحسب ما اعلن معالي المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ طيب تندم الينا من هناك مراسله
العربيه الشهد المتروك عشان ناخذ معها جو
لو نشوف فيها معالم العالم في الرياض اهلا
فيك معانا يا شهد الف مبروك طبعا
الفوز وكيف الاجواء عندك مع الفوز
يعني ساره مساء
فعلا لي السعوديه والشعب السعودي يعني هذا
النتيجه الساحقه والعظيمه طبعا اللي خلت
كل الخليج ربما يكون جدا
نتيجه واستمرار المنتخب السعودي على ان
يكمل ويكون في مباريات ثانيه طبعا الفرحه
هذه ما كانت فقط في الملعب القطري لكن
ايضا كنا اليوم في اكثر من مكان في مرسول
الباركو شفنا فرحه الجمهور السعودي لما
كان يشجع المنتخب الحين احنا نتواجد فيه
ايضا الفرحه مستمره ومبينه في او على كثير
من الناس خصوصا الناس صارت ترتدي العلم
السعودي او الوشاح السعودي وحتى التيشيرت
اللي يخص المنتخب السعودي كما ترين ساره
يعني احنا اليوم نتجول في دول العالم لكن
في منطقه واحده
طبعا امس كنا في همم في المغرب في الصين
ايطاليا اليوم همم راح نستم في همم
اليونان تحديدا طبعا هذه الدول من عشر دول
اصلا موجوده في بوليفارد ورد اليوم
البوليفارد يتزين باللون الاخضر احتفالا
بفوز المنتخب همم السعودي همم طبعا هذه
جوله يمكن ما تعطي حتى المكان حقه من كثر
ما هو فعلا يفوق الخيال همم هذا المكان
اللي فيه عروض كثيره عشر دول عندنا اكبر
بحيره صناعيه في العالم تاخذ السياح او
الزوار يعني احنا راح نسميهم سياح لما
يفترون دول العالم المختلفه همم ياخذنهم
فيديو ولا حول همم العواصم المختلفه فيه
11 محطه ينتقلون اليها همم مائيا عبر او
عن طريق القوارب في كل دوله عندها محطه
تنقل للزوار من دوله الى همم اخرى طبعا في
ايضا جلسات شفنا همم في وسط البحيره يعني
الناس تقدر تستمتع فيها القوارب ايضا
مصممه مبتكر خصوصا في ايطاليا على شكل
سيارات ربما هذا اللي صورناه وطلع امس حتى
همم ساره طبعا يعني
العروض لا تتوقف همم في البوليفارد ورد
الصين لهم طبعا الادراجون او اللي يسمونه
التنين اللي مشهورين في همم كنا في الهند
وكانت في فرقه هنديه قبل قليل اليونان
طبعا متميزه بتصميمها المباني البيضه
الزرقاء وهذا واحد من العروض اليونانيه
اللي موجود همم
يونان يعني اللي معروفه يعني في مبانيها
هذا واحد من
العروض الحيه اللي موجوده الحين طبعا ما
بين اليونان واليابان طيب خلينا نسمعوا
شويه يا شهد
يا بوني اسمعوني المشاهدين مباشره شويه من
راح اجرب المايك علشان توضح اكثر الاغاني
والموسيقى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طبعا مثل ما شفنا يعني هذا كان واحد من
العروض ساره يعني فعلا جميع العروض تفوق
الخيال كل الثقافات موجوده في البوليفارد
خصوصا اليوم صار المكان ازحم اكثر بعد فوز
المنتخب السعودي والاعلان عن دخول
البوليفارد سيتي والبوليفارد ورد مجانا
والله الكل فرحان والاجواء عندك حلوه يا
ريتني كمان جلسه عندك كانت سلينا مع بعض
واخذنا مع بعض
اكثر بنشوفك على خير كانت معنا مراسله
العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد والان معنا نشره اخبار ال
المصري اليوميه واللي صارت فقره اساسيه
عندنا خلاص على الاقل حتى اشعار اخر اليوم
اختبار او انتباهي يكون هو عنوان لسلسله
او هو اختار المتباه يكون عنوان للسلسله
تغريده القرار يستعرض فيها انجازاته في
تويتر في الكم اسبوع اللي فاتوا فنشر صوره
لرسم بياني وعلق عليه انه يظهر
مليون
مستخدمين الجدد واستقطابهم هو من اكبر
تحديات من الصوت الكبير وخصوصا تويتر اللي
معروف انه هذه من اكبر ازماته انه ما
بيجذب مستخدمين جدد علشان كده بيتبعها
بهذا الموضوع ومن امس ومزاج الى الماسك
مايل للتنكيت والضحك والسخريه ف بتغريدات
وقالتناولناها امس وكان بينك فيها وما ترك
احد من شره اليوم ما لقى احد ينكت عليه
فنككت على نفسه وقال وسط تغريدات كثيره
انه لحظه يا جماعه داحين لمن انا بغرد كده
هل يعتبر هذا انه انا جالس بشتغل يعني
بصراحه يعني الجماعه لازم يعطوا له راتب
اضافي على الساعات اللي شرس بيقضيها ماسك
يعني صراحه على تويتر هو جالس بيغرد وبيرد
على
المتابعه ما هو اصلا بيملك الشركه كلها
يعني معلش
خلينا نروح لعنوان ثاني من عناوين نشره
اخبار
الدفعه جديده من المطرودين وحسب الموقع
فعلا طرد ماسك دفعه جديده هو موظفي الشركه
الان صاروا 2700 موظف بعد ما كانوا 7,500
قبل ما يشتري ماسك لكن مع هذه الاخبار في
اخبار على اجتماع اللي ماسك مع الموظفين
اعلن لهم في انه خلاص الطرد خلص اما في اي
طرد جديد وعشان نكون واقعيين مشاهدينا وسط
كل اللي جالس بيصير ماسك عامل انقسام بين
الناس كثير جلسه بتنتقدوا وناس
تحديدا شايفين انه هو جالس به دمر منصه
تويتر وبيعمل قررت جنونيا ولكن كمان في
ناس بتحبه وشايفه انه لا يا جماعه هذا
الرجل عن جد وجهات نظر يعني عنده وجهه نظر
خلينا نقول عنده رؤيه مستقبليه ومعجبين في
صراحه لاقصى الحدود في تفاعلكم احنا
متابعين مسلسل ماسك معكم طبعا اليوم بيوم
من اول لحظه
ومراسل العربيه حسين موجود في سان
فرانسيسكو امام مقر تويتر وكمان بيغطي
القصه لحظه بلحظه هناك امس بناس من هذول
اللي حابين الماسك فمثلا كل الاقالات اللي
جالسه بتصير والاحتجاجات التقى بشخص قاتل
نفسه على وظيفه في التويتر
السيسي
[موسيقى]
اثنين
اللي شفتوه هذا لابس الماسك خوفا قال انه
خايف لو تعين في تويتر والناس عرفت انه
بيحب ماسك فيقوم ويقلبوا عليهم عموما غير
هذا مراسلنا كمان التقى بيوتيوب لو اكثر
من شهر امام المبنى املا في حضن بس من مصر
جهاز
منصات اليوم والاخبار عنوانها خساره عملاق
المسرح اللبناني روميو لحود اللي من الوقت
اعلان وفاته وما زال اسمه ترند على
المنصات
ومصمم استعراضات قدم على مدار عشرات او
على مدار عشرات السنوات الكثير من الاعمال
والحان المشاهدين احنا وصلنا او خلينا قبل
ما نوصل لفقره عرض اهم اعماله خلينا نتكلم
عنه كيف الكثير من الفنانين الراحل ونحن
مشاهديننا همم وصلنا الاختام حلقاتنا احنا
اليوم لكن في تفاعلكم حبينا انه نقدم
لفتره صغيره اللي روح الفنان الكبير روميو
الحوت وهذا هو المقطع اللي كنت بقول لكم
عنه اخترنا له مجموعه من اعماله تكريمه
قالولي العيد بعيوني
على درب بعيده دلوني
غمضت عيوني تشروف بعيد لا شفت العيد ولا
دربي بعيد
وابعت من
الليله
بكره بتشرق شمس العيد وبتبشر بنهار جديد
عايش ليهم
حبيه اليوم بايدك بكره بعيد
احلى عوايد عوده
الزمن بعوده
ايمان
يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
ياللي
نسيناك على عيني واخذيني
[موسيقى]
على
القهوه
اليوم الفرح
[موسيقى]